elle est devenue un symbole du mouvement
de protestation contre la junte
militaire
mia 20 ans a rendu son dernier souffle
la jeune femme qui a reçu une balle à la
tête lors d'une manifestation la semaine
dernière est morte après avoir passé dix
jours à l'hôpital
malgré la douleur sa soeur a saisi
l'occasion pour lancer un appel à la
mobilisation
je veux encourager tous les citoyens à
descendre dans la rue dit elle pour se
débarrasser de ce système
des manifestations sont organisées tous
les jours dans plusieurs villes du
myanmar depuis le coup d'état perpétré
au début du mois la junte militaire a
chassé du pouvoir en scène chick
alléguant des fraudes massives aux
élections de novembre largement
remportées par le parti de la militante
pour démocratie l'ancien dirigeant du
myanmar a été arrêté puis assigné à
résidence
la junte militaire mène une répression
de plus en plus sévères en plus des
canons à eau des gaz et des balles de
caoutchouc
elle aurait aussi utilisé des balles
réelles contre les manifestants qui
s'opposent à son coup d'état
plus de 500 personnes auraient été
arrêtées dont des étudiants nous
attendons devant la prison tous les
jours pour avoir des nouvelles de nos
enfants dit cet homme
mais il ne put sont détenus pendant ce
temps la communauté internationale
s'organise une masse vendeur ou un pacte
commencer il faut restaurer la
démocratie au meehan mardi le ministre
britannique des affaires étrangères
le canada le royaume uni et les etats
unis ont tous adopté des sanctions à
l'endroit de responsables militaires
birmans ici olivier bastin radio canada
montréal